carbon dioxide or CO2 emissions soared
to a record level last year by several
indexes Qatar ranks high globally when
it comes to CO2 emissions per capita
this November the gulf nation is
pledging to host the first ever carbon
neutral World Cup
a lot of people will come to the Qatar
by air but the activities here within
Qatar is designed in such a way that all
the emissions associated
there will be a limited emissions and
this emissions will be balanced the
layout of stadiums over a small
geographic area means once fans land in
Qatar they'll travel a relatively short
distance by Metro Electric bus or car to
matches and stadiums built with
sustainability in mind
after football's Premier spectacle is
over the CO2 emissions during the 28
days will be offset by investing in
carbon credits
but a report by carbon market watch says
Qatar 2022's carbon neutral plan is
misleading and based on what it calls
creative calculations
it is highly unlikely that this world
cup is going to be cover neutral it is
not a credible claim and there is a big
risk that it's going to mislead the
public into thinking that this has no
impact on the climate when actually it
definitely does
the organizing committee says qatar's
historic Ambitions should be recognized
not criticized it points to the almost 1
million square meters of green space
created and a new solar power plant that
will generate renewable energy for years
after the tournament ends We Stand by
our planning We Stand by our
calculations and we stand by our plans
to offset what's remaining in the best
possible way with the best information
that we have
a team from Qatar University will be
setting up weather monitoring stations
and sharing the daily air quality with
fans during the World Cup
the hope is it will spread awareness
about the impact we have on the climate
and how to reduce our carbon footprint
Natasha gname Al Jazeera Doha